الثلج هذا هو حال الاحتجاجات في فرنسا بعد
قيام الحكومه بتمرير قانون رفع سن التقاعد
من دون تصويت البرلمان تظاهرات واحتجاجات
تعم كل المدن والشوارع بداتها النقابات
والاحزاب اليساريه المعارضه والان يكملها
الطلاب الذين بات لهم تحركاتهم الخاصه هم
يتجمعون امام مبنى بلديه باريس للاحتجاج
على عنف الشرطه خصوصا وانهم كانوا ضحايا
قوه مفرطه استخدمت ضدهم خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه لكن هذا المشهد الهادئ في النهار
سرعان ما يشتعل ليلا بتظاهرات تجوب شوارع
ترتفع فيها السنه اللهب وتتحول الى فوضى
عارمه هذه التظاهرات الليليه العشوائيه
باتت تؤرق اجهزه الشرطه التي تنتشر في كل
الشوارع للبحث عن المتظاهرين لكن هذه
المهمه باتت اصعب بكثير خصوصا وان
انتقادات كثيره باتت توجه للشرطه التي
تقوم باستخدام العنف المخ اتجاه
المتظاهرين واحيانا تعتدي على الصحفيين
الحرائق المشتعله في الشوارع لا يبدو انها
ستنطفئ قريبا مع اصرار الطرفين على
التصعيد لقناتي العربيه والحدث فديدهوك
باريس